she's off living her life so what I've
learned is just to not expect too much
from her Brody Jenner getting candid
about his complicated relationship with
his dad Caitlyn Jenner on the second
episode of the hills new beginnings in
the episode Brody admits he wasn't close
to Caitlyn growing up before she came
out as transgender in 2015
Brody is the youngest son of Caitlyn
formerly known as Bruce Jenner and
actress Linda Thompson who was Caitlyn's
second wife before they divorced in 1986
after five years of marriage
Caitlyn later married Kris Jenner in
1991 and the to starred on Keeping Up
with the Kardashians together I didn't
really grow up with my dad I didn't
really you know when I was really little
we got to spend a little bit of time
when he started you know obviously the
family with the Kardashian family and
all that I didn't really see much of him
the 35 year old later says that Caitlyn
missed out on some big moments in his
life including his 2018 wedding to
Caitlyn in Bali I have been dating
Caitlyn Carter for four and a half years
and my dad came out and said
he wanted to be called Caitlyn to
Caitlyn's Bruce was just never really
around every so often maybe once every
couple years wasn't around for my
graduation wasn't around for most of my
birthdays
so yeah what really wasn't any
relationship it was very surface
eventually we started to become the
closer but then all of a sudden it's
like I was just getting to know Bruce
and then Bruce became Caitlyn did you
guys go hard on the green screen yeah
course we just needed to say what we
were really feeling and thinking because
that way you don't get into trouble it's
like that you really feel yeah so on the
green screens we said how he really felt
but Brody says he's supportive of the 69
year olds transition Caitlyn is a
totally different person than Bruce it's
her true self but Bruce was always
holding a lot back and being somebody
totally different on the premiere
episode Brody briefly mentioned his dad
while giving an update on his life since
the hills went off the air in 2010 but
Brody told et not to rule out a cameo
from his famous dad this season are we
gonna see any Kardashians any Jenner's
pop-up this season I don't know you're
gonna have to watch me find out
maybe Caitlyn could appear there's
always a possibility